she stopped ukraine's pleas for aid
found an audience in seoul
where president zielenski asked south
korea's parliament for the weapons to
win the war
what can be essential for us you haven't
he told lawmakers
battered bombed out and now bracing for
the next onslaught
ukraine sees little chance russia will
find reason to stop its attack
fresh off a visit to keeve and having
witnessed the horrors of bucha the
austrian chancellor met with vladimir
putin where he came to the same grim
conclusion
president
i have no optimistic impression that i
can report to you from this conversation
he said the next offensive is being
prepared on a massive scale
in an interview with state tv russia's
foreign minister lowered expectations
even further warning russia will not
stop its assault to allow for peace
talks
there would be no pause so long as a
final agreement is not reached and
signed said sergey lavrov
having failed to use the pen the west
will instead turn to the sword after
boris johnson made a surprise trip to
keeves saturday the uk says it will send
more weapons
the eu says it will speed up the pace of
weapons deliveries and consider
sanctions on russian oil and gas
the u.s says it's looking for ways to
bolster ukrainian air defenses
immediately we want to try to get them
long-range air defense systems that we
know they know how to use ukraine has
warned the lull in fighting is a
critical window for resupply ahead of
the next more brutal phase of the war
with diplomacy off the table the west is
still holding back from direct combat
but seems to have hardened its resolve
to give ukrainians a fighting chance
jackson proskow global news washington